[Music]
like to welcome everybody tonight's just
tactics class we're going to cover a
couple different topics the first topic
is where there is a work a bishop or a
queen that operate in a straight column
or diagonal it's important to remember
that the attacking piece can go beyond
maybe past a piece that's in the way to
a square past the piece and it's the
effect of its attack we're do a few
examples on that so that's called the
effect of an attack beyond the enemies
man and this the first example which is
right here on the board will show you
how that works this is a very simple
example but let's suppose that black
plays rook takes rook here that would be
a blunder of course because Bishop takes
Queen and the bishop would guard the e1
square so there would be no checkmate
now the the winning move though is quite
simply see how the the black rook
operates along the whole file and
indirectly attacks the bishop on a1 even
though there's a white work in the way
so the winning move is Queen takes
bishop check rook takes rook or it takes
or checkmate so this this example is
simple just to show the idea of the
topic
the first topic tonight let's go on to
the next example you can see that white
as the two rooks doubled on the King
file I work in e2
II won is the queen on D for the Queen
and Turks are attacking the knight on e5
the knight on e5 is defended by the two
pieces of bishop and rook so it looks
like work takes Knight Bishop takes rook
rook takes rook where it takes her a
queen takes wreck white can win two
pieces for a rook but that's actually a
blunder it's that's black up for our
topic tonight so white does try to do
that but that's a losing move similar to
the last example who wouldn't the
audience would care to say what the
winning move is right Queen takes and
then rook has to take that Queen can
interpose so it's not mate rook takes
rook and we won the exchange with that
white took the knight but we ended up
black ended up the exchange ahead with a
one game okay let's go to our next
example again we have to make a couple
ultimately black makes them a couple
moves that aren't the most accurate so
let's go right to it White's going to
win this game but again it depends on
black making some inaccurate moves the
first move black moves the work up to
attack the Queen it looks like blacks
trying to win the pawn on e5 perhaps
Queen goes down threatens Queen takes
for a checkmate black blunders and
ezarik takes pawn on e5 and like the
last example the winning move as Queen
takes direct check and then the work
follows so again the the idea is that
the work on e3
even though there's a wreck on e5 the
work is indirectly attacking the e8
square so he's affecting
blacks man the are on e8 even though
there's a wreck on e5 between them oh I
didn't finish it that's probably what
you're getting at the bishop can drop
back now there's a nice checkmate rook
takes Bishop and work down because the
bishop guards the Kings escape score
yeah that's what you're getting at so
that was good you brought that up now
this is a little unusual you would think
that this idea of a piece on a straight
line is a attacking motif which it has
been in our other examples but in this
example it's a defensive most motive so
the black bishop on h4 is attacking the
pawn on e7 and it looks like there's
nothing I can do to prevent losing the
pawn but white thinks he can play rook
to d8 threatening rook takes rook check
and if Bishop takes pawn then Rick takes
rook check would lead to checkmate but
black has a defense gets the bishop on
h4 not only attacks upon on e7 he has an
indirect impact on the d8 square so the
answer is rook takes rook pawn takes
Queen and Bishop takes pawn saves the
day and black wins the game being a
piece up our last example okay it's
white to play as you can see let's check
out the pawns there's three for white on
the King side three for black there's
four for white on the Queen side 4 for
black so the pawns are even they both
have two rooks they have a queen and
white as a bishop and a knight against
two knights white is attacking though he
has his night on the f5 Square attacking
the
on d6 and is Bishop on g5 attacks the
knight so White has the better position
now in this example it starts off with
the white does Rick takes Rick now if
black does pawn takes work we don't have
the the topic of tonight but a white has
the better ending after pawn takes
Knight but attacking through on the line
comes into effect if black answers queen
takes so it looks now like black wants
to try trade Queens Queen takes Queen
pawn takes Queen White would still have
somewhat of an advantage in the ending
but the the move of our theme tonight in
our last example is the Queen indirectly
is attacking the d6 square and the white
knight an f5 they're both attacking the
d6 core so white can play Knight takes
pawn and because the Queen's defended by
the bishop black wins the key pawn and
should win the game so that's pretty
straightforward
now we're going to jump to a different
topic how I passed you can use a passed
pawn drive it as a wedge into your
opponent's position so in the pet in an
endgame a fast pawn of course you try to
promote it to a queen and then you win
with the extra Queen but a passed pawn
can also be driven as a wedge into your
opponent's position and of course your
opponent has to block the pass pawn and
the pieces that block the pawn leave
open another area on the chessboard that
you may be able to attack so you use the
passed pawn in the middle game as a
wedge into your opponent's position
that's the basic idea let's run through
a few examples
so obviously here White has a passed
pawn it's on the pawn on d5 what and
interesting enough this example works
out to Black's benefit it's it's so you
can consider this example a defensive
example this example is how you can
block the passed pawn and actually get
the better position sometimes so black
is going to be a little better but let's
step into the moves white plays rook to
d1 he needed to protect the pawn you can
see that the pond is not protected and
the threats Queen takes pawn so the work
comes over and black mooses Rick over to
c8 to attack the pawn down on c3 and to
operate on that half-open c-file
white pushes the c3 pawn to c4 to
reinforce his past pawn on d5 so now he
has a protected pass pawn which is
usually good for for white now black
does a strategic retreat of his Knight
to b7 when your opponent has the passed
pawn on the fifth row like the pawn on
d5 you want to block it with either a
knight or a bishop if you can do it with
either piece the knight is the best one
to use the reason the Knights a little
better than the bishop the knight can
sit there on in this case on d6 and see
how it will attack the pawn on c4 and it
will also attack the square e for
allowing black to move is pawn on e5 up
driving the White Knight away from the
center of the board
so that's blacks plan white could could
maintain equality here but white makes a
couple wheat move
this rook to e3 is a weak move and it
leads to black getting some advantage so
black brings the knight up to block the
past pawn just like I was saying now
white could still get an even position
if he retreats his rook to e2 but he's
trying to attack that pawn on e5 so he
mistakenly moves the the work on D 1 to
e 1 and he's attacking the d5 the e5
pawn he temporarily threatens to win it
but it's it's a wrong idea because black
can just shove the pawn up 1 square see
how the knight blocks the past pawn on
d5 and protects the black pawn on e5 and
now the knight on f3 candy now I think
it go to to the square d 4 then the
knight would threaten to go into c6 and
white would probably be ok so going back
you can see that if this white work on
d1 had stayed there and black moved the
pawn to e4 the d1 work would protect the
d4 square and the knight could move
there which would be better for white
privy and even position that's why
moving the work off the D file to e1 to
attack the pawn is the wrong idea the
pawn comes up now the knight can't go to
d4 so it comes back to d2 and threatens
to win the pawn but now black has this
good move he brings the bishop he
activates the Bishop from f6 to d4
driving the rook back and black has the
better position
we'll stop here the computer evaluates
this is a big plus for black I didn't go
further into it but who in the well who
in the audience would care to make a
suggest a move for white in this
position how about you do you have any
idea where he should move his Rick yeah
that's his best it protects the f2
squared and the two works protect each
other and it threatened white threatens
Knight takes pawn on e4 Knight takes
Knight rook takes or it takes Rick takes
winning the pawn but unfortunately when
black moved the Bishop from f6 it
unblocked his pawn on f5 so black can
effectively protect his pawn with what
move f5 now look Black has two pawns
coming down toward the King side black
has the much better game let's go on to
our next example if it was White's move
white could win an exchange how could
white win in exchange if it was his move
any but ideas
he could fork the two rooks couldn't he
Knight to c6 black would probably work
takes bishop we could do the knight
takes the work and I think we could
extract our Knight and stay stay ahead
because that Bishop the knight could
possibly come back to c6 maybe we'd have
to look into it a little more but anyway
it's blacks move so he stops night to
see
oh it's White's move white plays g4 he
wants to attack black with his King side
pawns now the black F pawn it on the
surface you might think black could do
Knight takes pawn but notice it would
open the line of both whites Bishop on
e4 down to the h7 pawn and then of
course Queen takes pawn would leave
Czech king over and queen to h8 would
lead to checkmate so so that pawn on f4
can't be touched let's see what black
does black moves his Bishop to b7
stopping Knight to c6 white attacks the
Queen now white takes the bishop so we
didn't get our knight fork but we look
at that bad position of that black Queen
rook it's a it can't move anywhere but
backwards because of its the three black
pawns around it and on b7 it's
unprotected but white can't win it if
you've dropped his Queen to f3 all black
is to do is move that C pawn and then
the two rooks would guard each other
let's see what white does oh he did he
did attack it so that forces c5 so the
two works defend each other
but notice in this position there is no
pass pause that white deep on isn't
Paskus there's a pawn on c7 that would
prevent it from be advancing but after
here threatening the rook and now if he
retreats the rook then the knight to c6
forks the the two rooks so he plays the
pawn up but notice now we get a passed
pawn by playing we're gonna play d5 at
some point first white chooses to
retreat the knight attacking the Queen
the Queen moves back to c7 the pawn
advances now there's a threat of pawn up
one more score forking the Queen and
rook so the Queen moves over will you
advance the pawn anyway attacking the
rook on e7 now what I'd like you to
notice about this position see how the
passed pawns supported by the work on d1
and the knight on c4 and the pawn once
it gets to d6 it acts as a wedge in
blacks position and it divides blacks
pieces on the King side and Queen side
and they have to block the pawn and then
we have these white pawns on f4 and g5
that are going to advance the drive the
knight back and maybe advance to f6 and
attack the black king side so by using
by the the white pieces follow behind
the passed pawn driving black back and
white ends up with a crushing attack so
this is an example of how to use your
passport to get a very strong attack
okay so the work they work directly
treats
now the pond comes up so the question is
what happens if Knight to Knight to e5
what happens here there's a win here for
a white a forced win it takes one to it
three moves three moves by white and it
demonstrates a winning position so who
would like to guess what the winning
move is for white that's a good idea but
let's take the Black Knight off the
board first Knight takes now how about
your idea and now what and he can't stop
it candy the route can't get back and
the Queen can't get in front of the pawn
so the best he has to do Queen takes
pawn and we're in a workout so that
shows this example shows you how you can
okay now the so Knight to e5 didn't work
it's a little better to go to f8 but
look what we've done now White has
advanced he has a pawn on f5 and g5 all
blacks pieces have been there on the
first and second row and the night is on
f8 so all we've got to do is we can
attack on the King side but before we do
that it would be nice to drive that
Queen away from d7 now well we would
like to play Knight to e5 and attack the
Queen of course we can't do it now
because rook could take the knight but
what move could white make to
pear Knight to e5 well that would be
okay but then black had trade off rooks
and our work would be on our remaining
work would be on a one not protecting
the past pawn so there's a better way to
prepare Knight to e5
what Square d5 that's the right move now
the threat is Knight to e5 black really
can't defend its it moves the rook back
we get our Knight to e5 in the Queen has
to give way now we can advance our
passed pawn and attack the rook on e one
Queen takes Queen where it takes Queen
rook to d8 doesn't really help like
because we have a knight fork with
Knight to c6 but let's see what black
tries ok black just moves his rook over
to block the pawn notice how now
yeah Queen so the Queen the black Queen
is stuck on the Queen side our pawn has
been driven to d7 keep blocking the
Queen from protecting f7 so the winning
move is in fact Queen takes pawn check
now there are different ways to win here
the author has this Square pawn up
threatening mate now pawn takes pawn
threatening Queen over mate works too
but the author has a pretty mate Queen
takes pawn king over night to f7 and
what's the threatened checkmate what is
it
that's right and there's another one do
you see the other one that's right so if
the Black Knight moves to g6 stopping
the Queen to h8 we still have the knight
to h6 checkmate so that's a pretty kind
of a pretty example obviously white is
the only one who can get a passed pawn
here and it must be the pawn on d4 so
somehow we're going to get the pawn I
mean the pawn on d4 needs to advance to
d5 attacking the bishop on e6 but we
can't play d5 right away because our
it's unprotected our Bishop blocks the
rook on d1 so we need to prepare to play
d5 what's the right move for white we
remember you want to get that pawn to d5
what's the best way to do that yeah not
only does that that threatens d5 but on
top of that you're attacking the rook
gaining yourself a move and because you
you have both the bishop and the rook
even if the rook goes to d8 it doesn't
stop d5 so that's the correct move let's
see what black does he moves his rook
over to e8 so we obviously shove our
pawn up now he moves his bishop back
there so we made some good headway now
we need to decide how we can further our
attack one idea you said you had said
Bishop to g6 check well maybe we could
move the Queen somewhere where she would
threaten to go to g6 or protect the
bishop to go to g6 so we can try Queen a
g3 for example that would threaten
Bishop to g6 check that's the
possibility there's an the other
possibility is there's
nothing blocking our past pond remember
I said we could use the past pond as a
wedge so let's shove the past pawn up
now that blocks the Queen from
protecting the Kings side and it
threatens Bishop to d5 check at the same
time
now the only thing blocking our past
pawn from advancing further is the
bishop on d7 but black doesn't like that
check on d5 which would make his King
put his King in a bad spot
so he plays east six Bishop to e6
guarding the d5 square but that leaves
our pawn able to advance another square
but the question we have to think about
if we advance the pawn and he moves his
rook to d8 then he threatened to Erick
takes pawn and the question is can we
defend the pawn in some manner but so we
need to think about a little further so
we're talking about pawn up notice when
we move pawn to d7 we're not only
attacking the black rook but we opened
up the d6 square for our white pieces
and if we look a little further we see
that we have a move worked at d6
attacking the Queen and that bishop on
e6 at the same time and don't forget
that the black work is going to move to
d8 won't be protecting the bishop on e6
and that looks like a work sacrifice to
me a rook takes a six then we move our
Bishop and get a discovered check looks
like we should be able to work with that
for an advantage so let's see what
happens so pawn comes up work up there's
our work to desync very strong move
he goes to see Queen to see seven now
there's a drawback to going to Queen a
see seven it looks like white can't move
that rook on d6 because the answer would
be Queen takes Queen it's not a check
though the white King's on b1 but it
would be now if that black Bishop wasn't
on e6 to take it off the board then we
would have the nice discovered attack on
the black Queen by rook takes Bishop
check f5 the possibility is there
another possible another square we could
do the same threat how about going to d5
then we would actually pin the bishop
against the king I think either would
work but Bishop to d5 is a little more
accurate because the bishop is pinned
against the king and can't move so
that's the winning move and if Bishop
takes Bishop then we get our work takes
bishop check and Queen takes Queen with
an easy win so it was interesting to see
how the pawn could drive this big wedge
into black and disrupt blacks defenses
okay well this is easy from the point of
view that white already has the passed
pawn on e6 protected by a bishop on c4
and a rook on e one so obviously white
two playing win now White's ultimate
goal is to take that work on d1 and put
it down on d7 attacking the Queen and
the work would be protected by the pawn
of course we can't do that
work move until we get rid of the knight
and the bishop the knight on f6 and the
bishop we need to advance our pieces
there are no good there's no our other
pawns are back on the second rank so
there's no pawn moves to be considered
our two rooks are already in their ideal
positioning at d1 and e1 so they're no
rook moves to be considered the queen
and the bishop on f4 or attacking the
black squares it doesn't look like they
should move so we're really down to
attacking with our bishop on c4 and our
knight on c3 so those are the pieces
what's the winning move for white what's
the other choice
how about if we if we start with the
night we threaten the queen if we move
the bishop first we're not threatening
anything so you want to use the little
more forceful move which is to advance
with the knight now he can do Knight
takes their Bishop takes and then we
take back and it probably transposes in
this example black takes with the bishop
we take with our bishop he takes with
the knight and we have our work here and
we are now threatening or to d7 how can
black defend against rook to d7 any
ideas how about moving one of the rooks
over to d8 okay now notice that once the
black rook goes to d8 the Queen and rook
are on the same black diagonal and we
can attack them with Bishop to g5 now he
can interpose with Bishop to f6 let's
see what what's played Oh black takes
the pawn at b7 that's not a very good
move then it falls right into White's
plan white does the bishop check forcing
Bishop takes now Queen takes check
right here if the Queen interposes then
we can push our passed pawn attacking
the rook with a winning game so he moves
this King over and now we get work to de
7 and the Queen has to go to f6
otherwise we have Queen to g7 checkmate
so Queen the f6 and we just shove our
pawn up now obviously his only move he
has to protect his Queen what what does
white do if black plays Queen takes
Queen here do we do Rick takes Queen or
do we have a better move so black plays
Queen takes Queen
what's the winning move for white
what do you think okay Jason right check
winning a temple and then we take the
Queen and Warrick up so the only other
possibility has to protect the Queen so
he moves his rook up now what's the
winning move who sees the winning move
now
what's your winning of idea is anything
blocking our path pawn yeah and get a
queen check and rook takes Queen takes
and we are a wreck up aren't we so
that's the winner let's see I do believe
there's an interesting alternative here
though in this position remember the
line we just looked over was Knight
takes Bishop rook takes black could have
played better by play Knight to h5
attacking our queen and Bishop
now there's a good move for white here
does anybody see what the good move for
white is we have to move the Queen
where should we move the Queen well we
have to protect our bishop too so we
have to move it to a square next to the
bishop yeah that's the right move now we
have a so we move and we have a threat
Queen takes Queen now black is going to
attack our Queen now what's our best
move Jason huh
right pinning the bishop very nice
and then causing black defensive
headaches now if black plays c6 that's
not the best move it drives we just
retreat our bishop and if the rook comes
to F to e8 we can get our work into d7
queen retreats now the rook comes to f7
attacking the Queen and the bishop
winning the game so the best move for
black here is Queen takes rook pawn
takes rook takes e5 rook takes e5 Bishop
takes g5 but White has looked to the
eighth-ranked winning the rook and
having the past pawn to boots now in
this position black actually has a
defense remember he played c6 and the
bishop retreated black had a better move
he could move the rook on c8 to d8
why can't delay h3 then they can move
his rift here white retreats the Queen
Bishop Queen Queen the g7 and but
White's best move is to retreat to e3
and you see white is the better game
because of his past pawn and his Bishop
on d5 but there's no immediate win so
why I could have defended the position
remember in this position black made a
mistake Knight takes that brought our
rook up then black made the mistake of
taking the pawn giving us the Czech King
had to go we got our work in there and
then we got to advance their pawn and it
was all over so sometimes there can be
defenses but you have to check out all
your possibilities well the only one who
has a passed pawn in this position is
black he has the past pawn on d5 as the
knight on e4 and his Queens on in a good
spot well actually white starts out he
plays Knight to c5 attacking the bishop
so it looks like we're going to have to
defend the bishop or move it but
actually a stronger move is too advanced
or passed pawn attacking the bishop on
e3 Knight takes the bishop on d7 now
we've got a pawn on e3 and we're
threatening Queen 2f to check King over
we'd have Queen takes respond Tech and
the game would soon be over so white
prevents Queen the f2 check by blocking
it with his Bishop attacking the knight
but the knight can advance
protected by the past pawn the knight
forks the rook and the bishop the rook
moves now the other night comes in and
now we've got three pieces attacking the
bishop
that's only defended by a queen and pawn
so we're threatening to win a pawn white
really can't stop that he just moves his
king up but that lets the Queen come in
check the King moves up to h3
now we take oh and notice that we had a
choice of Knights to take we took with
the knight on D two because we want the
knight on d4 to protect the pawn when it
goes to e2 so that's why that Knight
took the pawn advances and now we
threaten Queen takes pawn check he
blocks it but that leaves the pawn
unprotected Queen takes pawn check the
Queen blocks the check and now we have
Queen to f1 check attacking the king and
rook and if we're takes Queen pawn takes
and we get our Queen back and we win a
rook okay let's go on to the next
example
okay well in this case black must be
winning he has a pawn down on d2
supported by the Queen in the rook let's
see how black breaks through oh well
white immediately blunders white plays
b5 not not a good move
it opens up that diagonal between the
two rooks that black diagonal from a1 to
f6
so black jumps on it with the Queen and
the threat is Queen takes Rickon a1
Queen takes Queen and then our past pawn
is unblocked we can do pawn to D one
Queen Czech Queen takes Queen rook takes
Queen is checkmate so that's a threat
and we're threatening the rook on f6 and
so he moves the rook and now we carry
out the Queen takes rook through it I
just mentioned okay now okay now the
author's even though Queen takes rook
wins the author points out that he could
avoid rook takes pawn on c7 check by
what move before he plays Queen takes
rook on a one what how could black snuff
out White's little attack on c7 with the
rook getting a discovered chat
any ideas
work the g3 yes Rick to g3 end of attack
on c7 new variation say pawn takes we
still have our nice little queen takes
rook and of course we get our queen back
he takes our queen and lo and behold
we're a knight up however the author
points that out but Queen takes Erick
still wins where it takes pawn check
King / rook here check but now we still
have work to g3 so I guess it works out
rook takes Rick check knight takes right
Queen takes Queen there's still a
winning move what is it
pardon yes work to c3 and there's no
defense because of the back row mate and
the pawn guards work to c1 so that wins
- well it looks like white as the past
pawn already stuck down on f7 we have a
rook on g4 and a queen on g3 attacking a
bishop on g7 this is a pretty meet I
challenge the audience to find the
winning moves white to play and win I'll
be impressed if you guys find it it's
tricky the bishop takes h6
that's a new move let's see if it works
so if I do Bishop takes pardon okay
any other ideas
I'm going to give you guys a hint
there's a Rick sacrifice what what Rick
can we sacrifice and where can we
sacrifice it rook takes Bishop yes now
obviously he has to do Knight takes okay
so that was one tricky part there's
still a tricky move what's the winning
move for white now no King takes bishop
that's right
Bishop to h6 and if this rook takes then
what Queen the g7 freeing are passed
pawn and we get a mating attack don't we
yes okay so far so so much for that one
but there's another way to take the rook
what's your answer now oh yeah we go up
this way and that's it isn't it
he had can interpose the Queen but then
pawn takes Queen is double check and
that's checkmate so well then it's okay
that this is pretty though look at say
we get a queen so we're checking by the
rook on f1 that's double check he has to
move the King here well and then we just
drop our Queen here and we get a
checkmate so that was kind of a pretty
example white to play and win we only
have three minutes so you're gonna have
to work fast
what should white do Bishop takes c6
I see what's a new move
is there a defense
work the d1 check so that's a good
defense what does the white do now
you
is there a better move for white I know
there's a master in the audience I'd
like to know his opinion let me prompt
you our queen and rook are attacking the
a7 pawn right how can we pile up on that
pawn with one more piece yeah I work 286
Oh work to D 1 but we can stop the
checkmate with Knight back rook takes
Bishop takes
and no way to stop c7 the night is in a
terrible position on the side of the
board and can't help the black queen
that I if I hadn't seen the answer
myself I don't think I would have ever
guessed all this let's go back so the
move is work here black tries check
night into blocks rook takes Knight
Queen back Bishop takes Bishop rook
takes Bishop right pawn takes blacks a
piece up looking good Queen takes pawn
chick looks like we have a perpetual
check doesn't it check but we don't take
the perpetual check we go to e4 then we
shove our past pawn he blocks it he has
to block it otherwise we have pawn up
check Queen now he has to retreat and
now we don't push the pawn we moved the
Queen and now we threaten c7 and he
can't stop us from Queen in our pot
that'll cover it for tonight thanks for
coming
[Music]
you
[Music]